شبحوا الجوع يخيم على الكثير من بقاع
العالم وارقام غير مسبوقه تدق ناقوس الخطر
من حدوث مجاعه في الكثير من الدول منتدى
دابست للاقتصاد العالمي لم يمر دون
التحذير من ازمه الرداء اسوء قادمه رئيسها
المنتدى برجر نفسه في تصريحات لصحيفه
الشرق الاوسط من تفاقم ازمه الغذاء في
العالم معبرا في الوقت نفسه عن قلقه من
ارتفاع مستويات فقط
لغه الارقام تكشف بالملموس ارتفاع مستوى
الجوع في العالم الى حد مقلق فبرنامج
الغذاء العالمي اكد ان عام 2022 كان عاما
غير مسبوق من الجوع حيث ان عدد الاشخاص
الذين يواجهون انعدام
ارتفع من 205 135 مليون الى 3450 مليون
منذ عام 2019
كما ينبها برنامج الغذاء العالمي الى انه
هناك نحو 50 مليون شخص على شفا المجاعه في
سنه 2020 من جهاتها حذرت الامم المتحده من
تفاقم من ازمه الغذاء على مستوى العالم
مؤكده ان نحو 30 مليون طفل حول العالم
يواجهون شبح المجاعه
اه الواو
بالازمه الاقتصاديه العالميه حيث ان
التوقعات غير مباشره كما تواجه اجزاء
كثيره من العالم ركودا اقتصاديا ويواجه
العالم باسره تباطئ في النمو وتفاق من في
عدم المساواه فضلا عن ازمه في تكاليف
المعيشه وهي الازمه التي تتفاقم بسرعه
السؤال المطروح الان ما اسباب زياده ازمه
الغذاء حول العالم خلال الفتره الماضيه
برنامج الغذاء العالمي اكد اضطراب سلاسل
التوريد منذ جائعه كورونا» ما ادى الى
ارتفاع الهائل في تكاليف الغذاء في 2020
ونقل عن برنامج الغذاء العالمي فان اسعار
المواد الغذائيه ارتفعت بنحو 20% على
اساسا سنويا كما ان التغيرات المناخيه وما
رافقها من ارتفاع في درجات الحراره ومن
فيضانات وجفاف ادت الى تراجع المحاصيل في
العديد من البلدان
واشتداد وازمه الغذاء لم يكن في من انا عن
ارتفاع معدلات الفقر حول العالم حيث من
المتوقع ان يعاني نحو سبعه في المئه من
سكان العالم من الفقر المدقع الى حدود عام
2030 وذلك نقلا عن تقرير للبنك الدولي هذا
وبلغ عدد الاشخاص الذين يعيشون في فقره
متعه مع نهايه السنه الماضيه نحو
685 مليون شخص ما يجعل عام 2022 ثاني اسوء
عام على مستوى جهود الحد من الفقر في
العقدين بعد عام 2020